Sam Holmes, do you recommend starting an LLC ASAP?
Go get a couple deals, then worry about it.
It's not that big of a deal.
This is not legal advice.
Eventually you wanna do it.
And I've heard people say like,
obviously you wanna go set up an LLC
because you wanna tell yourself
and you wanna tell the world,
you wanna act like you're doing this for real.
This isn't just some dabbling.
And I'm not saying that you shouldn't do it
for those reasons.
What I'm saying is that don't let,
oh, I don't wanna do any cold calls today
because I don't have an LLC.
Don't let that be the thing that stops you.
Go get some deals, man.
I did, let's see, I did the towing deal.
I did the basic waterproofing deal.
I did three or four deals back in 2016
when I first started this
before I even thought about an LLC.
I wasn't even sure this model still would work.
This is back to six years ago, okay?
So if you have somebody that could set it up for you
and whatever, just go, yeah, have them do it.
That's great.
Don't let that be the thing
that prioritizes making cold calls.
that prioritizes doing due diligence
or doing Zoom closes or whatever.
Make sure to prioritize the things that actually matter
versus the thing that is urgent, okay?
Sometimes those are the same thing,
but a lot of times the things that actually matter
are not urgent.
And so they get pushed to the back burner
and the front burner gets the stuff that's urgent,
but doesn't move the needle, okay?
Always be moving the needle.